hi there steve kaufman here
i have my um
bluetooth um speakers on
because as i was setting up here um and
whenever i'm doing anything i'm
listening to
to my romanian because i'm into romanian
right now
today i'm going to talk about
strategy what i consider be the
essential strategic consideration
in language learning
uh i'm keeping these on by they be
because i'm going to turn on my romaine
and mania shortly just uh for effect
here but
um i've said before that language
learning really amounts to
the attitude of the learner
the time you spend with the language
and developing the ability to notice and
this ability to notice is key because
your brain is going to learn but the
brain has to notice the language whether
it be
patterns in the language pronunciation
or whatever so what is the strategy
for
learning to notice
and if you develop a strategy for
learning to notice that then becomes a
strategy for learning the language
and to me the strategy
to notice and to learn the language
is to have a two-pronged attack on the
language
one is a top-down
and the other is a bottom-up or
bottoms-up
in other words one is the big picture
top down
and the other is the bits and pieces
which is bottom up
now what does that mean specifically
it means the top down the big picture is
the input which is where i spent most of
my time and the bits and pieces or
bottom up
is any attention you pay to
flash cards word lists grammar rules
grammar tables
even in the early stages speaking and
being corrected
those kinds of things
um
most of my effort with romanian has been
with the big picture
i've been at romanian for about three
weeks i've discovered radio romania
romania romania where they have the
history programs newscasts
unfortunately they don't have
transcripts
but i have gone to elance to see if i
can find the transcriber so that i can
transcribe some of these very
interesting history discussions
also in terms of the big picture i've
gone after wikipedia there's all kinds
of stuff on romanian history which i
import into link so i've cranked up my
linking my new words i'm up to 8 000 new
words in romanian
at least known words whatever that means
but but by and large if i now go to a
wikipedia article on romanian history
i know a lot of the words and the ones
that i don't know i look up and they are
going to my database at link and i will
eventually
know them so i've got a lot of
interesting
top down stuff happening
so far as the bottom up is concerned
before we had anything going at link
i bought uh pimsleur which gives you you
know a very repetitive and repeated
exposure to a small number of
phrases
um which is a form of bottom-up i bought
teach yourself so i was
going through the explanations there and
going through their dialogues and
picking up what i could pick up
and again i went on elance and i did up
i it must be i don't know
uh
40 episodes
of
you know sets of phrases
why because when would should present
future
uh
you know a whole bunch of stuff
that are patterns that i've put into our
link library for english
and now i've had translated into
romanian and i've had them recorded so i
also spend a fair amount of time
listening to these patterns so before i
go any further i will turn on my
handy
um
nano here and see where we are
we'll see what she says here
etc okay
okay
anyway i'll take this off now
so i mean i have heard those
hundred no not a hundred but lots and
lots of times so it's got all of the
although because however
uh greetings and stuff like that so
those are the bottom-up
uh bits and pieces
uh which i need to have a lot of
exposure to to drill them
into my brain and i prefer listening to
these because they are
first of all they're sentences and
patterns that i've written up because
they matter to me and i get to listen to
them over and over again
um
i prefer that to say pimsleur because
there's no english in these there's only
romanian and of course i have the
transcripts at link and i've saved all
the words and phrases and so i read them
again i listen to them again so there
i'm getting at the bits and pieces
but it would be boring if that's all i
did and my vocabulary would be limited
so i very much enjoy
reading
the wikipedia articles on romanian
history and listening to
the interviews on radio
romania and i would say you know i've
been at romania for three weeks uh a
week ago i couldn't understand much now
i think i understand about 50
there was the discussion there about the
byzantine empire and the influence on
romania and
you know the influence of the west
versus byzantium and so forth and so on
uh there was another discussion about uh
you know uh
what was this king king charles i guess
who was the uh holland zolan
german
prince who became the king of romania
around the time i guess of the first
world war i miss a lot but it's fun
and now i'm going to get these
transcribed elance so
i very much recommend
that your strategy would be one of going
after more difficult but more
interesting texts
to give your brain exposure to
the big picture but do it in an
environment
like link where you can actually read
what you're listening to look up words
that you don't know
and work on learning those
and i will sometimes review the flash
cards on on my iphone if i'm waiting
somewhere
and then vary that with easier content
where you are basically getting repeated
exposure to some of the fundamental
patterns of the language some of the
fundamental
structures
and some of the useful connecting words
and and whatever that you need in the
language
now
the way languages are taught you know
it's interesting i think
that most of the
um
i call them the youtube polyglots that i
know of the richard simcots the lucas
even
you know people from you know historical
importance like cat olam the famous
hungarian uh polyglot lady
their emphasis has been more on the top
down
on the uh the input
which doesn't mean that they you know
neglected the other but they did that
primarily and and the more they did that
i think the better they became in their
languages
however most instruction
focuses on the bits and pieces and and i
think the reason there is clear that for
a learner the most pleasing thing to do
the easiest thing to do is input
and uh for many learners at least it's
interesting it's easier to do it's it's
portable it's uh
less expensive
but and from a teacher's perspective
it's easier to teach the nuts and bolts
it gives you something that you can try
to teach
however unfortunately with the nuts and
bolts
that no matter how many times i read
explanations of grammar like in my
romanian book i'm reading them now for
the i don't know umpteenth time they
don't necessarily stick until a certain
point where we've i've seen them so
often in other
settings in other contexts that finally
it clicks in
so the deliberate study of the nuts and
bolts the deliberate attempt to teach
the nuts and bolts is doomed to failure
if there isn't at least twice as much
time
spent with
the big picture the input and again
getting back to the
my sort of the three keys it's not mine
i heard this from a lady at san diego
san diego state university you know
attitude time and the ability to notice
well if you're doing things that are
interesting you're going to have a more
positive attitude
uh your attitude towards the language is
going to be more positive
uh
in order to put in the time you need to
do things that are interesting
so
going after
the big picture interesting content
deals with the attitude and the time
issue
the noticing requires a combination of
both if you just expose yourself to
input
contrary to all the
research that crash and others have done
i don't buy it i know that there are
things that i just won't notice unless
it's pointed out to me
pointed out to me perhaps in a grammar
explanation or because i hear these
basic patterns over and over and over
again until finally oh yeah that relates
to what i've been you know noticing
or i start to notice it so
to conclude
uh my suggestion at least the strategy
that works for me and you don't have to
do what i say obviously and you won't
however you know i do have some
experience in language learning perhaps
more than the average language learner
and some degree of success
here i am with my romanian i've been at
it for three weeks
uh
obviously i'm helped by the fact that
the vocabulary a lot of it is very
similar to romance languages but i feel
very confident that
you know i've got a month to go before i
go to romania
and the radio romania um
you know podcasts are becoming clearer
and clearer to me
uh it's becoming easier and easier to
read i've only been out for threes uh
you know and i find myself now because
i'm also starting to speak with uh you
know tutors
that i'm able to start using some of
these patterns that i've been listening
to over and over that kind of been
dripping on my brain so i very much
recommend strategy of both
top down and bottom up but at least two
or three times as much
uh top down as bottom up with the uh
with the caveat that when you are
starting out the first of the while you
need more of the bottom up because you
can't access the top down it just so
happens in romania and i can do that i
don't think you know i know i couldn't
have done that in czech
because the vocabulary would be would be
too different for me so there it is
uh strategy
top down say three parts top down and
one part bottom up i look forward to
hearing your comments bye for now